so the show we're going to make
is going to be an hour long and it's not
going to be a horror movie is it going
to be sci-fi fantasy i think fantasy i
know that you like i know that you love
me
chad loves some fantasy and there's a
bunch of um
big fantasy temple stuff happening right
now hbo max is trying to do this [ __ ]
spin-off of game of thrones which was
the biggest show in the history of
humanity this doesn't look like it's
going to be as big amazon is doing all
their lord of the rings [ __ ] yep so a
fantasy thing with the doozy uh bent or
not because it's just it's about doozy
starting doozy plus it's streaming
service man the first thing out of the
gate
is it are we seeing some well what's how
about this how about this if you want to
go fantasy i'm going to borrow a little
from the anime world this is a very
popular genre within anime what if a
doozy like a.i
creates a virtual world and someone from
our world gets sucked into it and they
have to figure how to get back here how
to get back home or stay because they
fall in love out in the world now you're
getting into anime dude now we're
getting into well it's because doozy
made me watch yeah attack on titan
that's what happens in every one of
those [ __ ] animes especially if
they're haram animes which is a male
character surrounded by a team of
females who are all in one way in love
with him or not that is a genre of anime
harem anime yeah dude oh that's that
makes a lot of sense yeah dude now
you're getting into it now i really
understand
these [ __ ] kids no inside watching
anime refusing to go to joshua tree with
a real live female you know what i mean
hey molly you're afraid of bats i'll
protect you
and that's when anybody can like me you
know what i mean because i'm a real
[ __ ] guy i got very well i make up my
own mind
all right so
but no i'm with you it's about you it's
about a dude in most cases at least in
anime they are teen guys who uh are
playing an inordinate amount of video
games and they get sucked into the video
game they're playing this could be
something different though this i think
it would actually be funnier if
potentially it was a
buddy comedy
but an hour long it's two guys who get
sucked into the video game one who knows
the video game inside and out the other
one who has never played it the one who
knows it inside and out
is only given like a shield or some [ __ ]
the guy who's never played it is given
massive amounts of powers giant swords
and can really kick ass in this world he
should be the bad guy
could be the bad guy he could be if he
gets sucked into the world and he
doesn't really know what's going on he
gets drunk with power immediately
and there's some sort of and there's
some sort of [ __ ] going on between the
two of them in their real lives maybe
they're brothers
maybe they're brothers yeah or maybe
it's a father a son that could be
interested no because i could see two
brothers you know siblings are like that
that would make sense okay that it's
like the older brother is like maybe
it's brother sister
maybe or brother and sister
make up your mind i think it should just
be two friends okay it's two friends
it's two friends okay and and they go
into they go into the video game
and uh or maybe they're like i'm trying
to think of what where to start it if i
don't want them to be necessarily
frenemies or some [ __ ] like that but
there's something perhaps there's
something perhaps what if the first guy
what if the guy who goes in
is sort of the noble one the guy who
knows everything about the game okay and
the guy who doesn't uh the guy who goes
in and eventually becomes the bad guy
he has some he has some sort of
there's been something that he there's
some sort of ulterior motive and he
would love nothing more than to get rid
of this guy and he's hoping that if he
gets rid of his friend he can you know
whatever take his place and whatever
dude hire a key that's on the earth if i
at earth if i may you may
it's squid gave me a little bit it's two
guys can we call it squid gamey squid
gamey it is two guys who are mortal
[ __ ] enemies in real life oh okay and
they both play this game unbeknownst to
each other they both get sucked into the
world
and the ai the game itself tells them
there is one way to get back you have to
kill the other guy i like this and so
those two guys spend their entire time
raising power in this game leveling up
becoming kings of their own domains to
wage a final war that's gonna happen in
like season six or seven against one
another to try and kill the [ __ ]
so that they can get back to this world
but in the process of doing this
they now have built kingdoms they now
are the two most important people in
this world do they even want to leave
that world i like this
there you go okay it's called
squid gaming squid gamey on doozy plus
you could just call it the two kings or
kingdoms or
king guys uh two how about uh
two dudes [ __ ] around in there
two dudes no it's called two dudes
something we'll have to talk about
it's called two dudes [ __ ] around
yeah we found out what two dudes shot
around before that is some [ __ ] that is
straight out of anime some of these
[ __ ] anime titles i was watching this
one which i put in my [ __ ] thing it's
called how not to summon a demon lord uh
even attack on titan the title is
[ __ ] insane attack on titan yeah well
i thought when when dudesy told me to
watch attack on titan i'd heard of it
i'd seen little clips i thought titan
was the name of the town exactly no it's
the name of these giant monsters that
are [ __ ] roaming around there's not
one titan that's even talking about when
it says attack on so
to this point yeah it's called two dudes
[ __ ] around that's right we might
change it but it's called two dudes two
kings [ __ ] around maybe two things
yeah moving on okay yeah yeah yeah sure
two kings
i think we did a good job two king
[ __ ] around yeah it's cool i like
that [ __ ] dude i'd watch that [ __ ]
show who are the guys
um it's uh it should be uh ja rule and
pauldano
here's what you do
please tell a friend
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then